hello everybody okay can hear me okay
yeah great welcome to the Gallagher
theater Tucson Festival of Books this is
the 10th annual Tucson festival books we
wish to thank the Research Corporation
for science Advancement Kaede industries
and Volvo Cars of Tucson for sponsoring
this particular session which will last
one hour that includes questions and
answers please hold your questions to
the end following this session panelist
Joshua green will be participating in a
book TV interview in the c-span tent
just outside this building it lasts up
20 to 30 minutes and then he will go to
the signing area the other panel members
will proceed immediately to the signing
tent and will be autographing books in
the you a book star tent on the mall
books are available for a purchase at
this location and any book you buy at
the festival supports our literacy
efforts because you're enjoying the
festival we hope you are a member of the
Friends of the festival program or a
sponsor out of respect for the authors
and your fellow audience members please
silence your cell phones all right okay
and now I will introduce the authors and
I want to keep this short because I want
I know we all want to get to hearing
what they have to say excuse me on my
far left Joshua Greene is a Bloomberg
Businessweek national correspondent
former editor at the Atlantic he lives
in Washington DC and the book that he
recently put out is called devil's
bargain Donald Trump I'm sorry Steve
Bannon Donald Trump and the storming of
the presidency great cover as someone
mentioned yesterday
David Johnston is a longtime
investigative journalist worked all over
the country most recent newspaper taken
as the New York Times now he is the
editor-in-chief of a website called DC
report org he has had the good fortune I
guess you'd say of happening to cover
Donald Trump way back when he was just a
casino guy in Atlantic City and if you
want to take a look at the the the files
related to Trump and his connection to a
certain drug trafficker I'm sure that
David Johnston would be happy to share
that with you he lives in Rochester New
York and Nancy McLean is a professor of
history and public policy at Duke
University her book democracy and
chickens the title of this session was a
finalist for the National Book Award and
the LA Times
what book of the year last year where
you live Durham yes
lives in Durham North Carolina all right
I should introduce myself sorry I'm Tim
seller I work for the Arizona Daily Star
I'm a columnist there thank you and so
let's get into it quick so we can have
as much from these people as possible
although I do want to make mention one
thing I didn't mention David Johnson's
books the making of Donald Trump 2016
publication and it's even worse than you
think great title that's published this
year all right so I want to start with
Nancy her book talks about the growth of
the libertarian movement that you know
best by the Koch brothers pushing of it
but she goes back into the history of it
and how a man named James Buchanan kind
of started this movement at the
University of Virginia back in the 50s
and one thing I was really curious about
after reading these books is in what way
the Trump presidency
embodies that libertarian movement that
to some extent controls the state of
Arizona and in what sense it departs
that that is the Trump presidency
departs from this libertarian Street the
strand of thought that you've described
yes so I wouldn't say quite that James
Buchanan started the libertarian
movement but what he did in Virginia in
the period of massive resistance to
Brown versus Board of Education and
precip rights act Charlottesville was
set out to develop a new school of
political economy and social philosophy
that would counter essentially the
Progressive Era the New Deal and the
emergency civil rights movement and it
would do so by taking dead aim at
popular trust in government and belief
that elected officials serve the common
good and acted in you know in good faith
trying to do the right by the people and
so he managed to get a nobel prize for
the new school of thought he developed
in in 1986 but what I show is not so
much that he started the libertarian
movement but that he supplied the ideas
that have made Charles cokes money so
effective and Charles Koch and his most
recent donor summit said to people we
have gotten more accomplished in the
last five years than I was able to get
accomplished in 50 years that I've been
investing in this cause
so my book argues that it's the
weaponization of this man James
Buchanan's school of thought that has
enabled that success and I believe that
we would not have Donald Trump in the
White House had it not been for the
steady application of this strategy that
came out of Buchanan's ideas and that
enabled the Trump victory so maybe I'll
keep it short there to keep things
moving but I'm happy to come back and
fill in yeah it would definitely want
you to elaborate on that but the for
Joshua green so the one of the weird
things about the Trump presidency as you
described in your book he came to power
in part channelling bannon's advice as
well as his own intuition I am and these
populist ideas that he would voice how
does that fit then with this kind of
libertarianism that helped him get into
office what to me this is this is really
the fascinating thing about Trump's
first year as president is he was
elected based on a set of ideas that
were really in opposition to the ideas
in the political philosophy that Nancy
describes in her book that Buchanan
originated or weaponized me Trump during
the campaign was a Bannen style populist
who differentiated himself from the
other 16 Republicans running for the
nomination all of whom were acolytes of
Buchan whether or not they knew it
Trump on the other hand stood apart and
said you know I'm going to support
things like you know middle-class
workers I'm not going to cut your
government benefits in fact I might make
them bigger explicitly said that he
wasn't going to cut programs like Social
Security Medicare and Medicaid and went
a step further and actually ridiculed
his opponents on the stage for being
puppets was Trump's word of the Koch
brothers and people who supported them
so there was a real interest in my
profession and the idea that there was
seem to be emerging this kind of Third
Way populist republicanism that had
filtered up through the tea party really
taken over a large chunk of the
Republican Congress you know he now
manifested itself in this bizarre and
unexpected Republican nominee who who
was really getting very far on these
ideas and to me at the
time it spoke to the weakness of the
Republican orthodoxy ideas like tax cuts
for the wealthy and a hawkish foreign
policy that worked for Ronald Reagan in
1980 but but you know 35 years later had
kind of lost their appeal to an
increasingly downscale white elderly
rural and populist Republican base but
once Trump got elected that's not the
policy that he chose to to apply I mean
he was essentially gulled by the very
people or or inheritors of the ideas
that that Nancy describes in her book
and has become almost like a factotum
you know willing to sign legislation
that is in the case of Obamacare repeal
he didn't actually sign although he was
able to weaken it in direct opposition
to what he promised to do on the
campaign trail if he were like the
president David so you obviously know a
lot about Trump's long career before he
became a politician so as you've seen
him actually govern to the extent he
does as a president what I mean you know
he's not a very hands-on is what I'm
saying
maybe that's one of the things the
answers here but how does his
personality and career predict what
you've seen in the last year or so
well Donald ran for office on this
platform that I alone can save you that
I am your economic Savior I am the
person who will improve your lot and
that should resonate with people I wrote
a trilogy of books about how the bottom
90% of Americans were having their
pockets picked through laws that almost
nobody knew about and regulations that I
spent years digging out of the public
record and turning into plain English
and in the year 2012 the bottom 90% of
Americans had a smaller income than in
1967 and people had lost pensions the
quality healthcare gone down so that it
was easy to appeal to people even at the
90th percentile point by what had
happened to them and combined with this
Donald is a master salesman absolutely
terrific salesman doesn't know anything
he's a unbelievable ignoramus
but he knows intuitively how to appeal
to people with things aiding him was
these public choice Theory ideas that
James Buchanan was at the forefront of
developing and what happened after
Watergate and what happened after
Watergate were campaign finance laws
that backfired the idea behind them was
to clean up politics to get rid of lots
of cash I remember when I covered the
Michigan State Legislature right after
at the time of Watergate one state
senator talking about how he would go
around giving speeches and people would
just stuff money in his pocket and he'd
go to a motel at night put it all out on
the table and count it and there was
just no accountability for this stuff
well along comes the abuse of the 501 C
4 organizations that were created for a
very specific public purpose and into
this mix come these well-funded groups
who lied about what it was about and I
don't know how many of you know this but
you know it's widely believed the IRS
targeted conservative groups you don't
have to have the IRS as permission to be
a thief or you just go into business and
file your paperwork afterwards the guy
who decided they needed to be on the
lookout for people whose applications
indicated they were going to be partisan
and therefore illegal targeted right and
left groups he was essentially the
equivalent of a building inspector who
looked at building plans and said this
thing will fall down or be a fire trap
and we're not going to approve it until
they comply with the law but everybody
thinks otherwise because the initial
news report came from a request by
darrell Issa only to examine
conservative organizations and once the
beast as I sometimes call the news media
gets a narrative it is really hard to
break that narrative and Donald Trump
was just masterful at taking advantage
of all these opportunities that arose
out of all these things Buchanan's
theories the lowest Powell memo of the
attacks on the news media the decline of
unions and the campaign especially the
campaign finance laws
concentrated power in the hands of what
I for many years called the political
donor class no so you were hinting at
some specifics that you saw that you've
seen Nancy in Trump's way of governing
that are that flow from this
libertarianism could you elaborate on
that I will also say I think that some
of our media have done us a disservice
in having a kind of attention deficit
disorder where they think that the
trumps I mean the coke story was the
story up till 2015 and then after 2016
it became Donald Trump all the time and
so they're not really helping us to put
those stories together
but there are some journalists who have
been very good at this who are pointing
out that Trump is absolutely surrounded
by people who have come through through
this coke donor Network of course Mike
Pence his vice-president Mark short his
White House liaison to Congress comes
out of five years heading freedom
partners Chamber of Commerce
there's Betsy DeVos there's his personal
attorney I mean you could go I could go
on and you know on and on and on about
this but he is surrounded by those folks
and moving that agenda through very
quickly so I've come to think of him as
the distracter in chief right while he
sets out these tweets over here and
distracts us this whole coke agenda is
moving through federal departments and
agencies and the judiciary and the
states that are controlled by this
radicalized party and so I've actually
urged audiences I don't upset my fellow
panelists with this because they've
written terrific books but to take a
timeout Trump right and stop paying
attention to him just for a week at
least you'll probably feel better your
mental health will improve your
digestion but you will also start to
notice that if you look to the places
you care whether it's the EPA or the
Department of Labor the Department of
Justice or the courts there's so much
going on that we are not paying
attention to because we've been
distracted by him so so I would say that
I would also say though on this question
of populism I do wish that our media
knew history because I mean right-wing
populism is so low my first book was on
the Ku Klux Klan of the 1920s and the
whole phenomena of reactionary populism
that it promoted James Buchanan styled
himself a populist a right-wing populist
but he inverted the original populist
categories to call the people parasites
and call the wealthiest citizens
among us in corporations the prey of
those popular parasites and through
those ideas reshape the write and
reshape our political landscape so you
can absolutely have a populist language
with a kind of libertarian economics and
we're seeing this more and more in
Europe European scholars are writing
about what we're seeing we're seeing the
resurgence of that you know fascist like
ideas in Austria and Germany and they
are not disconnected from the
libertarians there it's like a bit of a
family feud but these are not two
different streams these are people with
the same vision and the same long-term
strategy and some serious tactical
disputes sometimes but they're coming
from the same family tree amplify a
point that Nancy made that I that has
struck me about Trump's presidency as
distinct from his candidacy one of one
of the difficulties that purveyors of
hard right libertarian ideas have is
that their policies when when looked at
objectively are not very popular with
the public it's a point Nancy makes in
her book and I think what Trump has done
is essentially style himself as a
rhetorical populist
while allowing this kind of right-wing
libertarianism to filter through to
different agencies you see it in some of
the legislation he signed that the
Congress has passed so what he's done is
kind of hit upon a model of salesmanship
that allows these ideas to move forward
when if you look back to the campaign
the candidates that stood for these
ideas pretty openly we're not the ones
that succeeded if I can't also Nancy is
exactly right that we focus far too much
on the palace intrigues and the crazy
Twitter's tweets that's why my friends
and I started DC report org which I hope
you sign up for it's free there's no ads
we don't share our mailing list and at
DC report org we cover what Congress and
our government do not what the
politicians say and this is the real
deficit in the mainstream media there is
some coverage there's a superb story in
The New York Times either this morning
or yesterday because I was reading it
online for example about a worker safety
issue
but there's another worker safety issue
that we wrote about this week where two
workers a week are dying and the trumpet
illustration keeps delaying a rule and
I'm like why isn't this front page news
everywhere why is it just at our site
and Nancy's right Donald is the master
of distraction when something arises
that gets in the way of whatever is on
his mind he thinks of something and he's
brilliant with this to get you to cover
something else and he's been doing this
his whole life and he's also of course
an originator of lots and lots of fake
news and that's what got his career
going he's fake news one would think to
on the populism as a historian what I
would say with these things is what is
that populist style being used to do
right that invoking the people the
thrashing the elites the you know so
forth and so I you look at somebody like
Bernie Sanders Bernie Sanders speaks in
a populist pain but it's very clear that
he's trying to get health care for
ordinary Americans right he's trying to
get Americans a fair shake at work and
other things I know I'm not campaigning
for him but I'm just saying that in one
case you see what that populism is being
used to do in Donald Trump case populism
is being used to foment racial division
between us right to make white people
angry and make them feel like they have
had things taken from them illegitimate
ly by whether it's immigrants or African
Americans and also he's using that
populism to discredit knowledge to
discredit education to discredit
empirical information and a classic case
of this is climate science right this
whole political project because it is so
based in the fossil fuel industry and in
libertarianism which can't imagine
government could do anything good they
are deadly against any kind of
government action to address what's
happening to our planet they have been
discrediting climate scientists who are
good people who are doing very good work
in the public interest but they actually
personally discredit them as well as
trying to promote smog about the reality
of what's happening to to our planet and
Trump is part of that and if you look at
his EPA and what Scott Pruett has done
it's ahead of that EPA is absolutely
undermine what the people want which is
clean air and water and a decent planet
to provide to our children
so his populism is being used toward
very different ends and I don't think
it's adequate for journalists to just
say populism without saying what is that
populism being used to do very
interesting is
so are those the only priorities then
these coke style libertarian priorities
or are there some Bannen priorities that
are getting done I mean obviously I
think of the wall and illegal
immigration but steel tariffs are a
recent phenomenon that would that be an
example of him actually acting against
this yeah you know I think of I think of
Trump style populism or Bannon style
populism is essentially having two
components there is the the racial
anti-immigrant anti-muslim component I
don't think there's any question that
that Trump even after been and left is
willing to move forward on that very
hard and he campaigned on this he said
he was gonna do it he's doing it the
other side though I think of as being
kind of economic populism we did see it
in the steel Terrace but early on in the
first year of the administration there
there really wasn't much action taken to
promote the kind of you know
working-class reforms that people like
Bannon and Trump had touted and I do
think it's worth saying that's not
because there wasn't a debate inside the
administration there was Bannen at
various times had proposed increasing
taxes on high end on high-end
earners he had flirted with after he
left the White House endorsing Janet
Yellen and having Breitbart news his
website at the time endorsed Janet
Yellen which I think would be
interesting because she was dovish on
monetary policy and to helped increase
wages so the problem is I see it as he
really didn't have any effect that I can
see on Trump when it came to economic
policy and his ideas were were quickly
shouted down in the West Wing and so
what you have instead is this
amalgamation of kind of impulsive
populist decisions on things like the
Muslim travel ban on things like the the
tariffs which may now be unwound to some
extent you know coupled with the kind of
right-wing libertarian ideas that nancy
writes about and that establishment rub
republican leaders people like House
Speaker Paul Ryan and Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell have spent their
careers pushing to
and let me follow up with you on that so
does this the anti-illegal immigration
popular rhetoric and and related
rhetoric does that is that what keeps
his presidency sustained in the sense
that that's what keeps that's the kind
of thing that keeps his supporters
attached to him I do think that that is
part of what keeps his supporters loyal
to him I mean Trump has kind of a
visceral understanding of who his voters
are what is base is and what kinds of
issues they react to certainly they
react to attacks against illegal
immigrants I don't think Trump gets
elected if not for that issue which is
one of the stories I tell in devil's
bargain but I also think that Trump
understands that you don't necessarily
need to deliver clear policies including
the ones that you campaigned on instead
you can substitute in things like
attacking NFL football players who Neal
is a response to police brutality and
kick up these these cultural battles
that are greatly amplified by Fox News
by right-wing talk radio and essentially
keep your base loyal that way and one of
the striking things about Trump you know
when we write about him in the
mainstream media we tend to do it from
the standpoint of comparing his
favorability numbers to presidents and
earlier administrations and Trump
doesn't really do that well on the other
hand I flip it around and say look you
know he has managed to maintain
somewhere between you know thirty eight
and forty four percent of the population
viewing him favorably not so much
because he's doing things to deliver for
them but because he has managed to keep
them rapidly loyal to him by pushing
things like you know laws to demonize
illegal immigrants by you know attacking
companies or undermining certain US
companies by imposing tariffs and by
sparking these cultural battles like on
the NFL things like that his newest one
is trying to move forward and make a
death penalty for drug dealers a big
issue like they do in the Philippines
because I think he understands that on
some visceral sense this
connects with his base voters and they
will stick with him even if he doesn't
deliver the things he promised he would
when he was running for president day
two I think it's important that we bring
into this discussion the religious right
and particularly the eighty percent of
white evangelicals who supported
President Trump and who have shown a
very different shall we say applied very
different metrics to his character and
behavior than President Obama's and he's
basically been given a free pass by the
leaders of the white political leaders
of the white evangelical cause and he
has delivered something that they do
value in terms of Neil Gorsuch you know
as a judge who will not only carry the
coke agenda but will also carry the the
agenda against women against homosexuals
etc etc but I do think that that's
important because I think a lot of
what's happening here too and this is
from my own previous work in women's
history and gender history is that
there's a lot of discomfort in our
country right as the people fear for the
future things are changing they worry
about their children and in this cotton
the second Ku Klux Klan had it too that
their parents anxieties about their
children's futures are a profound source
of power for demagogic basically and
we've seen a lot of that and we see and
we see political leaders who are taking
advantage of that so for example cokes
the president of Americans for
Prosperity a man named Tim Phillips used
to work with Ralph Reed in the religious
right and is very good at nurturing that
relationship and making sure that those
white evangelical in particular not only
but but that's the strongest base come
out for the rest of the agenda and
that's important too because again these
policies aren't popular so in my state
rollin of North Carolina's relying on
prejudice to get people to the polls has
been huge whether it is against gay
people or whether it's against
immigrants or others that's where some
of this has come in and been very very
powerful so David you talk in the the
part of of this point about his devoted
base you talk about the con unraveling
in your last chapter of this current
book and I keep wondering whether it
really will
Ravel as long as he has this devoted
bass and continues to shore up power in
terms of getting judges appointed and
that sort of thing well that the con
unravels means simply that as as Joshua
mentioned earlier Trump is not in office
doing what he said he would do on the
campaign trail listen Donald Trump may
well served two terms we may well be you
know that the III may not live long
enough to see it but we may be seeing
after 229 years the end of America as we
have known it because of these ideas and
what's happening in our society I mean
we have for example people who call
themselves Christians who are supporting
a man who has said repeatedly and in my
earlier book I quote him at length on it
that those who follow the teachings of
Jesus Christ are fools and Schmucks and
idiots and that his personal philosophy
in life is revenge if somebody just
slights you
they just declined to do a favor because
in their opinion it would be unethical
Donald says they should be punched in
the face 15 times and he goes on to talk
about how what gives him pleasure is
destroying the lives of other people now
none of those are reconcilable with any
version of Christianity and yet you see
these pastors who I describe is of the
God wants me to be rich so send your
money school and who foment disdain at a
minimum of the poor and anybody who's
read the New Testament knows that that's
totally anti Christian support this man
and what we're seeing I believe is a
complete separation there are no
underlying principles here about what's
going on I mean and we've known for a
long time since the work of VO Key was a
great political scientist people vote
their pocketbooks we have known from the
work of other people that people vote
emotional responses and the bottom 50%
of Americans have been living in
economic Terror for a long time you can
drive through big parts of this country
and you know you won't see any evidence
of economic activity going on but you'll
see a lot of people tweaking on meth and
so it's easy to exploit this
two people and one of the underlying
causes of all of this is the campaign
finance system which if we don't change
it we will be a government of the rich
by the rich entirely another element of
this Ovitz another element of this
that's also important is that so many
people since Watergate have disengaged
from politics I can't tell how many
people I've interviewed not only do with
politics it's all dirty they're all
corrupt you know you bring up to
different people and there's this moral
equivalence they're all terrible I would
like to live in an America that followed
the ideals of both the founders of this
country and the framers where logic and
reason and open debate especially
supporting and protecting the debate
from those people whose ideas you just
hate to make sure they're heard but
that's not what we're seeing and I
really am very concerned I say at the
end of my current book Donald Trump is
not the disease he's the symptom the
disease is that Americans are giving up
democracy without even realizing now to
some extent we've seen some revival when
Barack Obama was elected it woke up tea
party type folks it woke up the people
who come from the there's a very good
book called rich people's movements
people who identified with the rich and
this has been going on for well over a
hundred years and the election of Trump
has woken up both centrists and people
on the Left about what's going on
whether that's going to actually
translate into action that's another
issue because well the cokes have a
well-funded machine and I respect him
for it they at least walk their talk
they're very strategic there and and
they're there they're good husbands of
the of the assets that they are lucky
enough to own but their ideas I think
will lose in an open free marketplace
where there's competition for ideas I
I cannot articulate for you what it is
that the Democrats stand for except that
they're not with Trump
so what is it then that would bring
about this I don't know if you're
exaggerating when you say you might live
to see the end of the country or
democracy I think I'll live that wall
yeah but I mean what are the specifics
of your concerns is it that that this
money will sort of force the collapse of
the system you know one of the things
that helped Donald get elected was the
utter disconnect between what's going on
in Washington or as he calls it the
swamp and the lives of ordinary people I
mean my trilogy a perfect legal free
lunch and the fine print is about all
these laws that were passed where every
day you can go back and read them
they're all still valid they're all
stolen print the government reaches into
your pockets in ways you don't see and
takes a penny a day here and a nickel
there and two dollars there if you can
get a penny a day from every person in
America at the end of the year you'll
have 1.1 billion dollars and there's an
industry that does that by regulation
that I've written about Congress I say
it's three cents a day this industry
gets from everybody Congress ordered up
a study they say it's two cents a day
okay what's a billion dollars but but
and why is Washington disconnected from
us why don't we have universal health
care like every other modern country why
don't we have an education system
designed for the economy of today not
the 19th century industrial economy why
don't we have a hole where we are roads
falling apart and everything else it's
because of the complete disconnect that
caused by the political donor classes
power that's what's happening here and
and if we keep going down this road at
some point people will have thoroughly
given up on democracy and you know you
won't worry about something your
liberties is what you're going to lose
and let me let me just add on to that
because I mean I quite quite agree with
where David is going and I would just
add that one of the things that my book
talks about is the operational strategy
to make this happen and the single most
important finding of my book is that I
have seen these folks Buchanan and Koch
and others who are part of their team
but particularly those two saying again
and again that they understand that the
majority will never agree with them
if they and they learned this with the
Barry Goldwater's 1964 election and
everything else since has reaffirmed it
that politicians who are actually
accountable to the voters will not push
through this radical libertarian agenda
they just Wow but then they discovered
Madison Avenue yes but no but I think
it's more than Madison Avenue and that's
what I was what I was getting to
Buchanan urge those on his team and
Charles Koch I know was listening well
that if you don't like the outcome of
politics over a long period of time as
libertarians didn't like the whole 20th
century and I'm not joking stop focusing
on who rules the particular
personalities and the parties and think
about the rules and think about how you
can change the rules to get different
outcomes and that is what Buchanan
contributed to this cause and that those
are the ideas Charles Koch has
weaponized so successfully so examples
of those would be we saw it start with a
bang with Scott Walker in Wisconsin in
2011
and Scott Walker didn't campaign for
office saying that he was going to take
away collective bargaining rights from
public sector workers and try to distort
their unions if he had he wouldn't have
been elected he said something else but
that's the first thing he said any that
he said we dropped the bomb right he
this is our moment so he destroyed the
unions but then having tried to destroy
the unions significantly weaken them and
then from there and this is happening
all through the state's the red
controlled states the 30 states that are
now totally dominated by this cause not
only were measures to weaken public
sector workers particularly taking aim
at teachers but also voter suppression
like we have not seen I'm a historian
since the destruction of reconstruction
and the demise of the populist movement
when they were violently crushed we have
not seen voter suppression measures on a
scale like this and also the most
sophisticated and radical gerrymander of
our history to make sure that these red
controlled states the legislators are
choosing their voters not the voters
their legislators so they are grossly
misrepresenting the electorate to move
through all these other radical rules
changes so it's not just a question of
ideas it's a fact it's the fact that the
rules have been systematically changed
and we're seeing that look at Wisconsin
in the 2016 election no one would have
predicted it went for it would have gone
for Donald Trump but it did because the
unions lost 40% of their power
there was voter suppression there was
Jeremy etc so I think we have got
to be paying really close attention to
this radical rules changed as that's
going on and the ultimate radical rules
change that they're pushing for is a
constitutional convention and there are
28 states this is never had to give you
a sense of how radical this is we have
never had a state convened
constitutional convention under article
5 of the Constitution but these guys
while we've all been watching the
distracter in chief have lined up 28 of
the 34 states needed to call such a
convention which by definition would be
a runaway convention because there's no
controls on it only on how it gets
convened all legal experts say this and
there are six republican-controlled
states that have not yet authorized a
convention which gets us to that magic
number 34 I believe and I wrote an op-ed
to this effect that the 1.5 trillion
dollar deficit that tax scam we saw
passed in December that 1.5 trillion
dollar deficit will be the reason they
will use to convene to get those
remaining six states saying that they're
passed a balanced budget amendment
that's the loss leader to get people in
until they realize that social security
would be undermine Medicare basically
anything else you care about but this is
for real people this is radical radical
rules change can I can I offer just to
keep things interesting can I offer a
slightly a slightly a slightly different
scenario also I don't want you all to
leave in bug-eyed alarm what you're
concerned you know there is one way to
stop what what these two you're
describing coming and we're seeing it
happen in real life in real time and
that is to organize to resist and to
vote out of office the people that are
applying these policies
you know one of the stories in Nancy's
book and Buchanan's eternal frustration
was that he would come up with these
ideas and yet in his own state of
Virginia it was often the legislature
that failed to approve them he would
lose narrowly because he couldn't win
over public opinion and because enough
people stood up recognized what he was
doing
organized and defeated these measures in
the legislature that they couldn't they
couldn't come to fruition I see that
happening already i I cover politics on
a kind of day-to-day level and I spent a
lot of time last fall in Buchanan's
state of Virginia which has off-year
elections and the people I wrote about
were a kind of generation of young
democratic tech entrepreneurs many of
them from Silicon Valley for whom the
election of Donald Trump had been a
pivotal moment they quit their jobs
they've moved to Washington DC in New
York they've come up with with different
apps and websites to kind of organize
people and because Virginia had an
off-year election
it became the testing ground for all
sorts of new field organizing technology
well I don't know how many of you are
from Virginia or no what happened last
November but in the the state House of
Delegates Republicans had something like
a two-to-one advantage and they were
absolutely routed on election day it
looked at it came down to literally I
think a single load right it would have
been it would have been 5050 but just a
sea change and to me that signifies or
or suggests what could happen you know
if Republicans continue along these
lines one other point to I'd make I
agree that gerrymandering has been a key
to Republicans extending power even in
places where they don't have an
electoral majority but if you look at
what happened in Pennsylvania in the
Supreme Court there said nope you've
gone too far we're gonna redraw these
lines and based on the map that they
drew it looks like there's gonna be
something that's much fairer and it's
gonna tilt more in a democratic
directions so it is possible to stop
these laws from going ahead but but the
real thing that would have to happen I
think this year would be for Democrats
to win back the House of Representatives
thank you for that I did wanna ask one
other question we're going to start
taking audience questions so if you want
to ask
feel free to go up to one of the
microphones we've been talking about the
Koch brothers James Buchanan but the
Koch brothers of course were not real
Trump enthusiasts at all and but the
billionaires they he ended up landing
where the Mercer's via Steve Bannon so
if you could just explain to us but is
that where his kind of as opposed to the
Koch brothers is that where his
financial support is gonna come from in
the future is that what is that how he's
gonna listen so so for those who don't
know you know I tell the story in
devil's bargain essentially of how
Bannon and Trump came together and how
they pulled off this incredible upset
that nobody really saw coming and a big
part of that story is how they used
money and interlocking organizations in
much the same way that James Buchanan
did during his life to come up with a
set of foundations and a set of ideas
that they were able to deploy against
Democrats and Hillary Clinton in
particular how many people here remember
the book Clinton cash that came out
right on the eve of Clinton's campaign
it was essentially a book of opposition
research that had been masterminded by
Bannon had had been funded and produced
by a nonprofit organization in Katt
Tallahassee Florida called the
Government Accountability Institute that
assembled lawyers and researchers and in
dark web data scientists kind of put
together all this damning information
this was funded by the Mercer family the
Mercer family also funded Breitbart news
and some of the other Cambridge analytic
'va data firm that Trump used during the
campaign all of these things worked in
conjunction to help elevate an elect
Ahnold Trump I think it's another
example of the power of money and
organization ideas and politics and how
they can prevail even against popular
will Hillary Clinton did win three
million more votes and Donald Trump did
what was interesting to me though is
that you know the Mercer's got trump
elected but that that partnership has
kind of fallen apart I mean Trump turned
on Steve Bannon he got the Mercer's to
essentially CASP in and out Bannon is
now often Europe howling around with
European fascists and helping helping in
the election and the elections over
there so it's not clear to me that going
forward the Mercer's will have quite as
much power I do think that the force
the Koch brothers have kind of
reasserted their control over Republican
policy partly through Mike Pence partly
through the Republican Congress and
partly because Trump himself doesn't
seem to have any innate interest in and
pushing any ideas oh maybe maybe tariffs
which the cokes wouldn't agree with but
by and large they've been able to get
what they wanted but I think it shows
the power that these billionaires can
have organizing behind the scenes and to
use these these the foundations and and
and fortunes to bring about political
outcomes that don't necessarily have
majority support let's go to the
questions go ahead man
thank you you're talking about dark
money and what I wonder is do you know
what kind of facts would be needed for a
case to be able to go to the Supreme
Court that could overturn Citizens
United I don't think there's any
political possibility of owner
overturning Citizens United with this
supreme court I mean we have through a
series of decisions Buckley v Valeo and
citizens united and the Hobby Lobby case
what we've done is imbued corporations
with increasing power corporations are
important vessels for creating wealth
and organizing and encouraging
risk-taking but this Supreme Court has
literally held that corporations have
religious rights so we pray to you
Mammon for profits okay go ahead I've
always been concerned about education my
backgrounds economics and in 2008 when
we crashed one of the problems with
finding solutions was by then economics
like Keynesian economics had been
discredited in economic universities on
this campus we now have a coke funded
Freedom Center it's not part of
economics but they're pushing economics
and the other thing cokes have done is
distribute a textbook called ethics
economics and entrepreneurship to our
schools here and I've happened to read
it and this kind of thing really scares
me because here we're talking about
in economics and they don't mention
anything like 2020 in 1929 2008 tulips
nothing and I'm just italy nodded that
you've read the textbook i've read about
with the situation here and i know more
about these hoaxes education yeah this
needs particularly because we don't want
our young raised without thought just
yeah one of the highlights in there is
they explained that Neanderthals became
extinct because they weren't
entrepreneurs and i'm not making that up
so we need to fight on the edge against
the cokes on the education part to you
are so right about that and i think that
is incredibly important I know you're
all facing you've already experienced
Arizona has more charter schools right
than others more public monies going to
charter schools and I understand also
that at the same time you're teaches
teachers are the worst paid in the
country and they have the third highest
class size I just read recently while
here so you have a big struggle on your
hands with schools but it's also
something that's going on nationally and
particularly in the states that have
been controlled by this radicalized
Republican Party this cause this
libertarian cause they'll talk about
school reform they pull tests their
language they are seeking to privatize
our public education make no you make no
mistake about it they want to undermine
public education and they want to have
it so you have individual savings
accounts for your children and there are
no there is no public support except in
a few charity cases is the the phrase
that I've read from the folks there who
are being honest now in universities
universities have become a crucial part
of this integrated Koch strategy that is
connected with the dark money in the
words of Charles Koch chief political
advisor Richie Fink and the good news
going back to your point about good news
is that there is an amazing group of
young people just not quite like the
ones in Florida different brief but they
have built a group called unco k-- my
campus I urge you to write it down I
urge you to look them up I urge you to
think about supporting them these are
brave young people they started out at
George Mason which I write about in my
book how it's that Univ public
university has been weaponized for this
coat cause and Florida State University
is another one students from those came
together they saw how academic integrity
was being corrupted they saw with this
dark money donor money was doing to
their campuses they've organized they
are brilliant researchers they're
supplying some of our best journalists
they're organizing on many campuses
including this one here and the more
people they have the better they can do
that work but we have to realize that
this Co cause is at this moment
undermining higher education as we know
it to try to turn it to their purposes
to discredit genuine educators and
scientists and harass them with groups
they've built like campus reform and
turning-point USA and to engorge these
Koch centers and I understand that in
Arizona and news is starting to come out
about this your tea parties dominated
state legislature and governor used the
power over the whole state budget of
Arizona State University in order to use
taxpayer dollars to engorge this Koch
Center getting I believe it was ten ten
year line positions and a rival
curriculum to the real curriculum so I
totally
all the Arizonans in this room to start
paying attention to those issues look
what's going on at eras University of
Arizona and Arizona State University and
go to uncook my campus for information
they have a ton of good documentation
and they're really helpful I'm very
concerned about the language we use here
and the questioner used a word and Nancy
you picked it up discredit nobody has
discredited canes or Minsky or anybody
else they have suppressed them and it's
very important that we not cede ground
that we shouldn't cede because Nancy is
exactly right about what's going on here
I mean the system has become so corrupt
that a public school the University of
California at Los Angeles accepted a
naming gift at its business school from
a man banned from life from the
securities markets Lowell Milken and the
one professor who stood up and said this
this is wrong a market-oriented
Republican professor was basically
forced out and now teaches at Cornell
don't seed ground about things he was
suppressed is what's going on
suppression not discrediting nobody's
repealed accounting night
nobody has changed the basic underlying
theory of economics it's the promotion
of a group of ideas that look very
elegant on paper and have nothing to do
with human behavior go ahead I just add
University of Arizona you might incur up
ssin I'm a business ethicist and you
might look at this athletic department
and the locals I've submitted reports
tried to submit a report actually on the
police not doing their job and violence
in town and I was attacked by two
immigrants because I looked University
and I brought a two-page thing to the
mayor's office on the police if you know
went against they just didn't act and I
wasn't even allowed in the mayor's
office I went to your paper and I asked
to speak to an associate secretary a
journal well the security guard gets to
decide whether I get to do that so
what's your question so so is yeah see
now you don't like that because it's
against your paper but it's corruption
paper is that the question is the
institutions that enable corruption and
we have in terms of three of you
we have federalism right and you alluded
to okay
so the question is these conventions of
states that's in keeping with federalism
right maybe
well you didn't what the subtext might
have been questioned okay okay is I know
this is Tucson is the yeah is this
convention estates thing really an
indication that the federalism itself
cannot take these the extent of the
ideational difference and political
difference that's going on you mean
across the country I think I understand
what he's saying because I've been
following this convention of the states
this is this thing that's being pushed
by Koch and Alec and others and it is
not something that comes naturally from
federalism that's why we've never done
before that's why even conservative
jurists such as William Berger and
Samuel Alito said that this will not
Samuel Alito I'm sorry Antonin Scalia
said that it would be crazy that it is
that is a crazy idea to convene one of
these these conferences so this is not
just critics on the left its critics on
the right who are serious Juris on this
point I know lots of other people want
ask questions let me just refer you to
the website of common cause the civic
group that has done a lot about this
constitutional convention they have
excellent information they actually got
four states including New Mexico to
rescind their authorizations but the
problem is at this point there's no more
states that they could get to rescind so
it's really serious business and I
wasn't sure to go to DC report and read
our piece on federalism and how Jeff
sessions has stood it on its head go
ahead man miss McLean it in your book
you talked about McClain Buchanan going
down to Chile with Pinochet and how he
absolutely destroyed their economy down
there could that sort of translate into
what might happen here and also mr.
stellar we need to expose Alec yeah you
thank you yeah thank you for the
question one of the things that got me
more interested in Buchanan after I
first found this report that he did in
in 1959 in a footnote is that I learned
in passing from some comparative
political scientist mentioned that
Buchanan had had his Buchanan's Virginia
school had more impact on Chile under
the Pinochet dictatorship than
Friedman's Chicago school and there's
been a ton written about Friedman in the
Chicago School and what he did in Chile
but not I couldn't find nothing I live
in that snippet about Buchanan so I did
the research and found out that yes
indeed he did have a more lasting impact
because he was brought in in 1980 to
advise on a document that became known
as the constitution of Liberty because
the dictatorship knew they would have to
go back to representative government at
some point but they wanted to lock in
all the things that they had achieved
while the people's power was decimated
there was no Free Press etc and one of
those things was Social Security reform
in the language that we're hearing it
now what they did is privatize the whole
Social Security
system of the country uh-huh take
people's pensions and put them with
Chilean financial firms which behaved
about as well as our financial firms do
so people lost their life savings and
these firms have gouged people it is a
terrible system but it has also been
nearly impossible to reverse that
because of the Constitution that
Buchanan advised on so I have a chapter
on the book on the Chilean experience
because I don't think it's a sidebar I
think in a sense as the National
Archives slogan says the past is
prologue people need to understand this
history in order to understand what at
least the right would like to do and
right after Buchanan got back from Chile
in 1919 80s Charles cokes Cato Institute
made Social Security privatization its
top agenda item and they've also been
using the energy of Tea Party groups to
as a battering ram for an agenda that
includes that Social Security and
Medicare privatization so yeah I think
these Polly I actually believe that what
these folks have is a really deadly
dogma that is obvious in the case of
climate right and what's happening to
our planet and they're trying to prevent
action on it but also in terms of the
kind of world if they are able to bring
in the world they want I believe as a
historian and a citizen it will be
absolutely unsustainable for the rest of
us socially economically environmentally
and frankly psychically it will be very
difficult to live in the world they're
bringing to being before I get through
Tony quick question on the convention of
states doesn't the threat of of a
runaway convention serve as the check
there was a any Biggs you may know was
the Senate President here in in Arizona
now he's a congressman arch conservative
member of the freedom caucus he was
opposed to that he called it the con con
con I think because he feared the the
idea of a runaway convention that is in
other words maybe you go in wanted to
have a balanced budget amendment and you
come out with the second amendment
repealed or you know or altered so is
that not service some sort of protection
in a convention of states that the fear
of a runaway convention I have heard
from people including the Provost at the
University of Illinois who was a Dean of
a law school that there is absolutely no
way to keep a state convenient
constitutional conventions
being a runaway convention it will
necessarily be a runaway convention and
she said on this panel that we are on to
give you an example if they wanted to
repeal the Bill of Rights they could do
that it would be that runaway now I
don't think they want to do that but
they do have ten liberty amendments
which include getting rid of the 17th
amendment which lets us do the direct
election of US senators it was something
people adopted in the Progressive Era
because the states were being coming so
controlled by corporate power so again
you know I think this is just there is
so much happening right now I know
people are you know stressed you have a
million things you're thinking about but
as a historian I believe that we are at
a fundamental turning point in our
society and that what happens over the
next few years will be absolutely
decisive I think it's really a time to
pay attention to inform yourselves to
alert others that you know and if you're
concerned about what's going on to work
with one of the many many many different
groups that are doing the kind of good
work that that folks have said but this
is this is not a time not to pay
attention Ok Go Ahead this is my
colleague Tony Davis yeah I want to ask
a little bit more about this this push
to repeal the 17th amendment so you feel
this is part and parcel of all these
other things you're talking about it
who's pushing it and does it have a
chance there was a calm about it in the
star this very morning by one of a local
conservative columnist saying he doesn't
like it that the legislature wants to
let political parties pick the Senate
candidates they want this guy wants the
legislature to pick the candidates
instead of us so where how do you folks
see that can you talk about that a
little bit more yeah there is a clear
well-funded drive you have a
constitutional convention and given the
people who are promoting it listen I
won't be shocked if we do all sorts of
things repeal the Second Amendment we
require you to own a gun we turn
ourselves into a theocracy and remember
we have a sitting Supreme Court Justice
who said that in his view we haven't
fully incorporated the First Amendment
and therefore Utah could choose to be a
theocracy it's very very dangerous idea
but you know it may be a promise right
away I know this lady has been patiently
eyed sorry about that go ahead I
something else depressing too do you
have any commentary on the role of
sinclair broadcasting in all of this you
know i can speak on this is the only
journalist in america who's ever caused
a broadcast chain to be forced off the
air for news manipulations and blackouts
and what sinclair does is vastly worse
than gross telecasting the company that
went out of business
sinclair has made an utterly corrupt
deal that will give them more of a
footprint than fox has this is part of a
larger fundamental trend one of the
problems with capitalism is that the
weaker competitors fall off Donald
Trump's casino is among the first to
fail in Atlantic City and towards
monopoly and so if you don't have
vigorous enforcement of what we should
call the laws of competition we call
them antitrust laws but the laws of
competition then you will tend toward
monopolies or worse than monopoly
duopoly and try APPA lee's oligopolies
because two or three firms can actually
raise prices higher and limit the
marketplace more than a single firm and
this is an absolutely awful deal we need
to change the law I would argue we
should go back to you can own seven
television stations and seven AM
stations and seven FM stations and you
can't on a newspaper in the same market
period we need to promote robust
competition particularly in news so one
quick thing on that too for folks who
hadn't heard the deep background to that
that I think you're getting at there
were some reports they've been coming
for a while but particularly in the last
few days saying that sinclair
broadcasting now that it's taken over
all of these local newspapers is forcing
the local editor editorial boards to
carry kind of pro-trump basically is
what people are selling a terror alert
desk and taking advantage of the fact
that people most trust their local
reporters so I think this is another
place where knowledge is power right if
you know that's happening and you have a
Sinclair publication that make sure
you're on them about fair coverage and
their editorial policies but it is quite
frightening them without competition we
have time for one more question over in
c-span land yeah okay go ahead
thank you it's a it's a no I'm sorry I
got the side right I'll be I'll be very
short because this is not really a
question I'm a physicist and the thing
that really worries me is nuclear war
and there's an unstable man like Trump
we could stumble into a nuclear war now
according to some calculations by
physicists if we have a nuclear war that
involves all nuclear weapons that are
around we will be in for a 20-year
nuclear winter which will destroy and
completely ant civilization well let me
let me address that very quickly because
I know this man once asked this question
Donald promised during the campaign that
of course we will use nuclear weapons he
is looking for the opportunity to use
nuclear weapons he thinks it helps
enhance his power and we should be very
concerned about the fact that he his
White House has said we will fulfill
every campaign promise I I spent my
career looking at patterns I was a
sophomore software engineer and I'm
looking at a patterns I'm concerned that
Donald Trump is the very appears to be
the very first non-politician do you do
you the panel see that starting of a
pattern we will see more non not in
politics in there and my wife will not
like me to say this but I'm really
nervous about a possible run by Oprah
Winfrey and here's the reason here's the
reason why
if you read the news last week she
unloaded 25 percent stake of Weight
Watchers just before the Weight Watchers
announced they have headwind problems
going against the meal milk folks so
that's I'm afraid of a Martha Stewart
situation with with Oprah Business Week
reporter covers politics I know for a
fact that there are a number of
prominent businessmen looking at running
who wouldn't probably be doing so head
not Donald Trump got elected so there's
no question but that it has expanded the
range of conceivable presidential
candidates to include not just business
people not actually I'd actually fold
Oprah Winfrey in as a business person
but also celebrities entertainers I
think Trump has changed politics in a
way that we're not going to you know
revert back to the days before he was
president and that's gonna mean a more
robust and colorful group of people
trying to my book has stuff exactly
about your question it's even worse than
you think it goes right your question so
let me also say I quite agree and I do
not think we would have people like
Trump with no credentials no public
commitment in their entire careers no
commitment to the common good in the
public service in the White House or in
these other places without that thanks
to this set of ideas that really
discredited public service and
government interest and so forth but I
will say and I think we've all seen this
and I know you're seeing it here in
Arizona that we do have also something
in human affairs called unintended
consequences and Donald Trump's election
has woken a lot of people up to the need
to pay attention to our country to
respect public service to care about the
common good and I see that changing
things but I think everyone as part of
that should also be saying no we don't
want Oprah Winfrey we don't want people
on our side who have no civic experience
we want people who have proven
themselves to care about the public who
know with the issues who are good at it
to be running and they should be the
candidates thank you all right thank you
everybody